مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي
يختتم دوره مرصعه بالنجوم تيلور سويفت
شخصيه العام انجلينا جولي تتحدث عن حياتها
بعد برادبيت وشريهان ترفض الاحتفال بعيد
ميلادها اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع السلام عليكم جرا اختتم مهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي فعاليات
دورته الثالثه المرصعه بالنجوم بتكريم
نيكولاس كيج بجائزه اليسر الفخريه تقديرا
لمسيرته الفنيه الممتده لاربعه عقود وحضر
حفل الختام هالي بيري جوين بالترو جيسون
يثم اندرو جارفيلد وادريان برودي والعديد
من نجوم السينما العالميين والعرب وانشدت
في الحفل مغنيه الاوبرا السوريه لبانا
القنطار رائعه الراحله اسمهان يا طيور يا
[موسيقى]
طيور
غني حبي
وانشدي وجدي
وامان عالميا اختيرت نجمه البوب الامريكيه
تيلور سويفت كافضل شخصيه لعام 2023 من
مجله تايم متغلب على باربي والملك تشارلز
الثالث وقالت مجله تايم انه تم اختيار
سويفت لانها وجدت طريقه لمنح الناس في
جميع انحاء العالم الامل في بعض الاوقات
المظلمه للغايه اجرت المجله ايضا مقابله
مع سويفت كشفت فيها ان هذا هو اكثر ما
شعلت به من فخر وسعاده على الاطلاق
والاكثر ابداعا وحريه على
الاطلاق وفي مقابله نشرت مؤخرا في صحيفه
وول ستريت جورنال وصفت النجمه الامريكيه
انجلينا جولي هوليود التي نشات فيها
بالمكان الضحل وغير الصحي وتحدثت عن
التعافي بعد انفصالها عن براد بيت و فسرت
جوري تقليص اعمالها خلال فتره الانفصال
والبقاء معظم الوقت في المنزل مع اطفالها
قائله كان علينا ان نتعافى واضافت هذا جزء
مما حدث بعد طلاقي لقد فقدت القدره على
العيش والسفر بحريه
ساتحدث
وبالع اوده لاخبار المشاهير في العالم
العربي رفضت النجمه المصريه شريهان
الاحتفال بعيد ميلادها هذا العام بسبب ما
يحدث في غزه ووجهت رساله مؤثره لمعجبيها
عبر حسابها الرسمي على منصه اكس قالت فيها
اخجلوا من اي نوع من انواع الاحتفال حاليا
ولو حتى لمجرد ساعات محدوده في هذا اليوم
وهذا الوقت الصعب جدا على نفسي واوضحت
قائله سامحوني فما تبقى لي هو عدم التناقض
وقلبي وعقلي الذي لا يستوعب ما يحدث في
العالم وانفاسي الاخيره التي ساقابل بها
ربي ومعهم رفض اباده الشعب الفلسطيني ورفض
قتل القضيه الفلسطينيه ورفض ما يحدث للشعب
المدني الفلسطيني في غزه بجميع فئاته على
حد تعبير النجمه
المصريه ونختتم الابرز بخبر رحيل المنتجه
المصريه ناهد فريد شوقي عن عمر 73 عاما
وتنتمي الراحله لاسره فنيه عريقه فهي ابنه
الفنانين الراحلين فريد شوقي وهدى سلطان
ووالده الفنانه ناهد
السباعي